so EU membership seems to have boosted
the city's economy but it has quite won
the hearts of all the people why is that
let's ask for catia deputy CEO and
managing director of international
economic affairs at di HK that is the
association of German chambers of
commerce and industry is good to have
you with us could it be that EU
membership also has its downsides for
the Czech Republic and where are those
problems exactly me first of all that
what you have you take for granted and
you some don't know where it comes from
and a lot of working places in the Czech
Republic are stemming from the EU
enlargement and for instance from German
companies invested in the Czech Republic
and now created abroad in the country
technology and brought in the working
places are responsible for more than
eighty percent of the check export so I
guess it's it's really welfare creating
and the enlargement was a success story
not only for Czech Republic but also for
the the German manufacturers is this a
reason why the you decided to continue
this would you call a success story back
in 2007 they were to look more members
Bulgaria and Romania the EU now consists
of 28 members how many more can the EU
stomach economically and why why does it
need to expand I mean we had concerns
look where we were discussed in Germany
the example of the Polish tambah who
could destroy competition and and could
trigger dumping it is a process costs
countries yeah on the web that all
hasn't happened and so therefore we can
think about further enlargements but
first of all we should think about more
integration creating the internal market
fulfill the internal market to have all
harmonize regulatory framework in in the
different market of the European Union
ok that's a good sort but it's not
exactly what's happening i mean the e
use
move further towards the east it trying
to establish closer ties with Ukraine
basically ended up with splitting
ukraine in pro-western and pro eastern
Ukraine resulting in the current crisis
with Russia has the EU has Brussels
underestimated the situation of that
region maybe yes but we have criteria
which should be fulfilled before
priority but it comes to then you
accession candidate so and this criteria
Ukraine hasn't fulfilled before but now
with this political crisis we can
rethink our criteria and maybe should a
bit weaker in order to make an offer
earlier for countries like the Ukraine
and countries like Belarus Oh moldovia
or Georgia that first of all I would the
chest Serbia and Bosnia Herzegovina the
Balkan countries okay so extension yes
but at a slower pace that's okay that's
it ok forget fire thank you very much
for being with us